alors le cpdr c'est prononcé c'était
prononcé pour accorder une subvention de
100.000 euros à une association qui en
avait d'ailleurs soluté 140000 je dis
bien ce que c'est PDF c'était prononcé
pour mais sur une décision du cabinet
donc il doit y avoir un lien avec vous
l'association n'a finalement rien obtenu
est-ce que vous pouvez
vous en expliquer les raisons est-ce que
vous avez le souvenir de cette décision
j'ai pas beaucoup d'éléments factueux à
ma disposition et je n'ai pas de
souvenir précis des échanges en comité
de sélection qui remonte à plus de deux
années
si on a une réunion du Nord du Nord
trente le souvenir que j'ai et les
éléments dont je dispose me permettent
de dire ou de vous redire que les
propositions faites par l'administration
ont été presque intégralement validés et
que entre les notes du préparatoire et
de sortie du comité j'ai relevé très peu
de différence
ma question à ce point est dans la
question du rapporteur en fait c'est que
comme pour tous les dossiers pour cette
association là il y a une note préalable
du
cipdr et que le 20 mai au comité de
sélection cette association est retenue
et que par contre il semblerait
que par mail d'un membre de votre
cabinet le 2 juin le financement soit
retiré
ce qui voudrait dire
pour poser la question autrement qu'il y
a eu
un comité de sélection
comité de sélection il y a
il y a une proposition qui qui sort
qui est faite par ce comité de sélection
et que dans les jours qui suivent
il y a encore des modifications qui se
font hors comité de sélection si je puis
dire par le cabinet
là dessus nous avons reçu un mail très
clair pour montrer qu'il y avait eu une
sortie d'une association après le comité
de sélection et alors que cette
association avait été retenue est-ce que
vous pouvez est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire si c'est la réalité ou la
réalité on a les mails bon
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça c'est à
dire l'idée que finalement il y a un
appel à projet on en a parlé il y a un
comité de sélection on en a parlé mais
que le comité de sélection finalement
n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga et n'est
pas la fin de l'histoire et que dans les
jours qui suivent il y a encore des
modifications sur ce dossier est-ce que
vous pouvez nous confirmer ce point
alors
en comité de sélection le 22 mai nous
entrons en réunion avec une note du
célibataire qui propose 15 dossiers qui
propose 15 dossiers à à validation
et qui en annexe 7 autres qui sont qui
sont
[Musique]
proposés
pour pour discussion
sur ces sept projets sur les 15
projetsalistes principales je crois
qu'en comité de sélection nous les
validons
presque tous à l'exception d'un seul qui
sera capable après discussion parce
qu'il est considéré que les actions
proposées sont des actions qui sont
intéressantes pertinentes les porteurs
du projet sont par ailleurs d'une grande
qualité mais on est sur des
interventions en milieu scolaire qui ne
sont pas des actions de conditions
numériques cette action est écartée pour
cette région là sur les 7 associations
qui figurent dans l'annexe et donc ils
font une discussion particulière en
comité de sélection il y en a trois qui
vont être retenues
en tant que lauréat à des niveaux de
financement qui sont inférieurs à ce qui
était demandé pour des raisons
d'enveloppes budgétaires
il y a une association
qui de cette quatrième association de la
liste annexe qui n'est donc pas proposé
par le cipdr en financement au titre du
fond Marianne on n'est pas dans liste
principale et qui dans l'échange qu'on
peut avoir au cours du comité puisque
c'est un échange mais la collégialité
je pose des questions mes collaborateurs
aussi les le cipdr il y a le secrétaire
général et ses collaborateurs il y a une
discussion collective et sur cette
association de vous citer avec une
demande à 140.000 euros le comité de
sélection dans les conclusions que Jean
dresse à l'issue du comité est retenu
pour un montant de 100.000 euros
cette liste deloreats naturellement je
rencontre à la ministre pour lui faire
part des décisions qui sont envisagées
et nous avons sur cette association
une réserve de la de la ministre en
raison d'un historique de relations
assez anciens et par ailleurs dans les
jours qui précèdent ou qui suivent à la
fin du mois de mai
une mise en cause par WordPress
de d'un membre de l'association
vis-à-vis de la ministre ce qui
conditionnit sur ce point qui était un
point de discussion important comme
cette sélection et qui relevait d'une
d'un arbitrage ou d'une confirmation par
la mite nous avons une décision de
non-sélections sur cette association
donc il y a bien eu sur les décisions
arrêtant comme petit sélection pour l'un
de ces lauréat
une affirmation par la ministre
[Musique]